[MUSIC PLAYING]
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: Hi, I'm Kelsey
Hightower, a staff developer
advocate for Google
Cloud Platform.
ARMON DADGAR: And I'm
Armon Dadgar, co-founder
and CTO of HashiCorp.
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: This is
the first video in our series
covering open-source
tools from HashiCorp
and how we can use them
with Google Cloud Platform.
In the next few
videos, you're going
to learn about using Vagrant,
Packer, and Terraform with GCP.
Armon, can you briefly
explain those videos?
ARMON DADGAR: Sure.
You know, Vagrant is
a pretty popular tool
that many people
have maybe played
with or at least heard of.
And it's commonly used to bring
up a development environment
in a quick, repeatable manner.
Packer falls sort
of right after that,
helping people to build
those machine images
and build those sort
of environments,
either for development, so
build images for Vagrant,
or to build
production-oriented images,
for example, a GCP, a VM image.
And then Terraform
is kind of next
on the kind of
development-to-production
lifecycle, and it helps people
provision infrastructure,
whether that's a
vSphere cluster locally
or a GCP cluster in the cloud.
KELSEY HIGHTOWER:
So if I'm a user,
I'm hearing all of these tools.
I'm like, that's a
lot of puzzle pieces.
Can you touch on how you tie
all of these tools together?
ARMON DADGAR: Sure.
I think this really
goes back to kind
of our mission at HashiCorp and
why the company even exists.
When we started the
company, it was really
to look at that
application delivery
process from development
through to production,
and say, like, what are those
pieces that you really need,
the necessary and
sufficient components?
And then building an open-source
tool to do each of those things
so that you can
provision, secure, and run
any type of infrastructure
for any type of application.
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: Awesome.
And users who I know have
played with HashiCorp tools,
they all tell me it's like all
the tools have a similar look
and feel.
Is there a common approach you
take to building these tools?
ARMON DADGAR: Yeah,
I'm glad you asked.
There's a document
we've published
called the "Tao of HashiCorp,"
where we talk about what
the design principles and
kind of the core philosophy
is behind kind of our
approach to infrastructure,
as well as our approach to
actually building tools.
And that comes across
in kind of the look
and feel of the
tools themselves.
KELSEY HIGHTOWER:
So I think that's
one thing that sets
HashiCorp apart,
is how this look and
feel of the tools are.
Can you talk about
some of the principles
behind that look and feel?
ARMON DADGAR: Sure.
We outline all of
them in the "Tao."
There's maybe six
or seven of them.
But I think the three that
are kind of the most important
for people is a
focus on workflows,
infrastructure as
code, and immutability.
The workflow focus for us
is very, very important,
because our view is that
users are going to bring
their own technology, right?
So some users,
they're going to be
living in a world of
vSphere and on-premise,
and how do we meet them there?
And other users are
going to be fully
in the cloud, running
everything in GCP,
and how do we support that?
And other people are going to
cross this entire spectrum.
So that's sort of
our focus on workflow
as opposed to technology.
And then when we get to
immutability, the idea is--
how do we avoid changing our
applications, our machines,
our infrastructure in place,
where we might introduce errors
into production and
then cause things
to fail in sort of
unexpected ways,
and instead build brand-new
versions that we fully know
and understand and can vet?
And I think then the third
kind of most important one
is this notion of
infrastructure as code, which
is another technique to kind
of manage the complexity
and make sure we can go to
large scale in a sane way.
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: So I
have a lot of experience
with infrastructure as code.
But maybe for some of the
people out there watching,
could you give me a
little bit more detail
about what
infrastructure as code is
and what it means to HashiCorp?
ARMON DADGAR: Yeah.
I think it's a
pretty general idea.
It can apply to all
sorts of things.
But I think the kernel
of it is this notion
that what we're used to is
having sort of in our heads
the idea of how our development
environment is built,
how our clusters are managed.
And what we're
really trying to do
is take that that's
locked away in our head,
and bring it in and
have it live as code
that actually can be executed.
Right?
And this way we can
version control it.
We can reuse it.
We can share it
with one another.
We can extend it over time.
And we can really begin to apply
the best practices of software
development to infrastructure
management, right?
And so the goal is
to kind of get away
from the oral tradition where
you're like, Bob in the corner
really knows how everything
works, and nobody else does.
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: All
right, so let's be honest.
Is this technique
unique to Terraform?
Or do you see this
technique in other places?
ARMON DADGAR: So it's a
bit loaded, because I know
you used to work at Puppet.
But you know, I think to give
credit where credit is due,
I think this idea was really
first pioneered by the config
management community,
where they really
realized that it's getting
increasingly complicated
to manage a modern server.
So just understanding users
and packages and files
and directories and
permissions, blah, is too much.
So how do we have all
of that live as code
and be able to
manage our servers
in this programmatic way?
So I think the config management
community really pioneered it,
and now we've taken
that and are applying it
to sort of the broader
HashiCorp tool chain.
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: Awesome.
So you talked about
this focus on workflows.
How does that focus on workflows
affect HashiCorp and GCP?
ARMON DADGAR: Yeah,
that's a great question.
Like I said, for
us it's this belief
that we have to meet our
users where they are, in terms
of their technology choices.
And for us, a huge
part of our community
lives and operates
and consumes GCP.
So for us, it's really important
to make sure with Vagrant,
you can have a
development box on GCP.
With Packer, you can
build images for it.
Terraform, you can
manage your GCP clusters,
so on and so forth.
It's that all of the tool chains
should integrate with GCP,
because that's a technology
choice users want to make.
KELSEY HIGHTOWER:
All right, so hey.
Thanks, Armon, for
joining me today.
How can more people learn
about more of HashiCorp tools
and the philosophy
behind HashiCorp?
ARMON DADGAR: Yeah,
thanks for having me.
It's always a pleasure, Kelsey.
I'd recommend people visit
our homepage, HashiCorp.com,
to learn more about the
company and the tools.
Or alternatively, people can
just watch your talk on YouTube
that you gave at Hashi-Con
about delivering a 12-factor app
with the Hashi stack.
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: Cool.
So hey, thanks
everyone for watching.
Don't forget to
subscribe to the channel
to keep up with more of
the open-source videos
in this series.
We've got more to
come for how you
can use other open-source
tools with GCP.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
All right.
Thanks for watching.
Make sure to check out
these other cool videos
on the channel, and don't
forget to subscribe.